بودابست المجر هي واحدة من جواهر أوروبا الخفية ،
وهي نقطة جذب سياحي معروفة
بتاريخها وهندستها المعمارية
الجميلة وحبها للماء ، ولكن في حين أن معظمها
فوق السطح تحت المدينة هي
عالم سري تحت الأرض ،
فإن عاصمة المجر هي موطن لأكثر من 80 من
الينابيع الحرارية الجوفية وعشرات من الخفافيش
كلها ساخنة بسبب دفء الأرض العميق
تحت السطح حيث
تدفقت هذه المياه المسخنة بشكل طبيعي تحت المدينة ، حيث
نحتت مئات الكهوف مما جعل
المدينة موطنًا لأكبر مجموعة من
الكهوف الحرارية في العالم
[موسيقى
] جوهرة تاج هذا النظام هي
اكتشف كهف مولنار يانوش في
القرن التاسع عشر على يد يانيش مولنار الذي تتبع
مياه الينابيع الدافئة من البحيرة في
الخارج إلى مصدرها تحت المدينة
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
بدأ الغواصون استكشاف الكهف لأول مرة
في الخمسينيات منذ ذلك الحين تقريبًا أربعة
أميال من الأنفاق رُسِمت
[موسيقى]
باللون الأسود الحالك لأميال الكهوف من
الحبل وقد تم مدها للغواصين لاتباع
المسار الصحيح للعودة إلى  يكون الخروج من
الماء دافئًا بشكل طبيعي بين 70 و
80 درجة فهرنهايت ،
يمكن أن تتراوح غرف الكهف من صغيرة إلى ضخمة
كبيرة جدًا بحيث يمكنها استيعاب 350
حافلة ذات طابقين وحتى في
الحياة شديدة السواد وجد
علماء الأحياء طريقة  حددت الأنواع الجديدة
التي تعيش فقط في هذه الكهوف ،
ولا يزال هناك الكثير من الإجابات حول هذا المكان
لتذكيرك بأنه حتى في أكثر المناطق الحضرية
لا يزال بإمكانك العثور على بعض من
أعظم عجائب الطبيعة.